hello everybody I don't have a mic but
this room seems good acoustically I hope
everybody can hear me yes okay so I'm
Ryan Hansel your latest guest speaker
during for this course I'm deep mind as
I guess all of the guest speakers are
for this course
I have been at deep mind for about four
years and I lead a research group in the
deep learning team in particular my
research focuses on aspects of continual
learning lifelong learning transfer
learning so I think that that's actually
incredibly important for getting deep
learning deep reinforcement learning to
work in the real world I also work on
robotics and miscellaneous other topics
that come up and so I'm going to talk
about sort of three topics and then if I
have time that I've got a little segment
at the end that shows some research that
I've have been working on recently which
maybe gives you just sort of a
fast-forward to just a method the
details of a method that's currently out
there being published but I'm going to
talk a fair amount about topics in
computer vision so this is actually a
continuation of what Karen Simonian
presented I think two weeks ago so
forget everything that oriole said last
week and remember what Karen said and I
will be continuing from that starting
with talking about beyond simple image
recognition or image classification so I
wanted to write so quick overview
talking about end-to-end learning as we
go to more complex architectures and
more complex tasks also doing a little
case study of an end-to-end trained
architecture and the spatial transformer
network then learning without layer
labels so how to do how to learn and
embedding or manifold if you don't have
supervised labels you don't want to use
them and then like I said a topic on
using reinforcement learning sequence
learning auxilary losses together for a
navigation problem a maze navigation
problem first of all and to end learning
it's a familiar term I just wanted to
make sure we're on the same page about
it somebody tell me what end-to-end
learning means someone right so
fundamentally we're talking about
methods that we can optimize all the way
from some input or all the way to an
output that we want and that everything
in the middle should be optimized
together and usually we do this by
differentiable approaches such that we
can use gradient descent methods to
optimize the whole thing at once end to
end and I have a little slide that I use
when I'm trying to convince people that
aren't necessarily into deep learning
why and to end learning is important so
this is a you know proof via history so
in 2010 the state of the art in speech
recognition looked like this you started
out with for speech recognition I've got
an audio signal that comes in and I want
to predict text from it that speech
recognition and so the state of the art
for doing this involved having a nice
acoustic model a nice phonetic model and
a nice language model all good machine
learning problems in of the
selves but a modular approach right each
of these things were optimized
separately but these definitely gave us
the state of the art and speech
recognition which was not bad in 2010
then in 2010 things changed the state of
the art was handed off to a deep neural
network that trained the whole pipeline
end to end going all the way from the
output that we want text back through
back to audio and getting an improvement
in that so sort of throwing away the
understanding of the domain experts that
said well first we need to get the the
you know we need to get the phonemes we
need to have the language model we have
need to have these different explicit
components in 2012 computer vision you
know state of the art was something that
maybe it was like this obviously
different variations of it but it
involved extracting some key points in
an image computing sift features some
other robust feature maybe training a
deformable part model and before you get
out labels so pixels to labels by this
sort of modular pipeline of separately
trained models and of course this was
exceeded by a lot in the image net
challenge using a deep neural network
that simply took pixels in output labels
again in 2014
machine translation text in text out and
this has also the news the state of the
art since 2014 has been different
flavors of deep neural networks so right
now state of the art and robotics looks
like this you have your sensors you do
some perception on that sense on those
sensory streams you maybe put these into
a map or a world model then you do some
planning and then you send some control
actions to the robot before actually
producing the actions to me you know I
really like robotics and I would love to
see this method replaced again with
end-to-end learning because I think that
it's obvious that there is a potential
here to take exactly that say you know
to take this
domaine do the same thing it's harder
for robotics I'm not going to talk about
it today but I just like to sort of
think about this as a reason for why
it's good to learn things and to end do
you buy that is that is it a convincing
argument all right let's talk about
beyond imagenet classification and so
one thing that we can do so Karen talked
about how to train convolutional neural
networks to solve a sort of image net
type of problems
I believe I hope that's what he talked
about yes and so let's make the point
first about pre training so training big
models on big datasets takes a lot of
time it can take several weeks on
multiple GPUs to train for imagenet
maybe not anymore used to take several
weeks still takes takes a while and a
fair amount of resources but the network
trained on a big data set like image net
should be useful for other data
especially if we have similar classes or
a similar domain but actually people
have shown that they can take a network
trained on image net and use those
features and use that for a wide variety
of new types of problems and in
different domains and that's really I
think the exciting thing about the image
net work both the data set and the
approach so how do we make use of a
trained model so we train our model the
trainer our big neural network we then
plug it into another network and we
train whatever layers we have that that
were not replaced using these pre
trained layers and then we can take that
keep those pre trained weights fixed or
we can slowly update them so this is a
simple process so train step a train the
confident on image nut which produces as
the output a thousand dimension
imagenet class likelihood vector we keep
some number of layers there sometimes
all of them whatever that model is
sometimes only some of them out of that
layer and we we initialize a new
continent using some of those pre
trained layers and then we can say well
I've got a last layer maybe got a couple
last layers in this case the output for
detection might be a twenty one
dimensional class likelihood for Pascal
vo C I guess that's not it's not
detection but classification and so we
just retrained that last layer that can
speed things up dramatically and it can
also be provide actually a better result
especially if you don't have enough data
in that new new data set all right let's
look at a couple of other image
recognition tasks image classification
just says there's a person there's a
sheep there's a dog or in the case of
image net its I always find image net
strange because you take an image like
that and the desired output label is
simply dog so it just it just outputs a
single single layer and you know throws
away anything else in the image so image
classification is is fairly blunt let's
think about harder tasks so we might
want to do object localization or
detection so that means we actually want
a bounding box around different things
basically that's saying I want a
classification of what the object is and
also a bound around where it is and
implied in that is that it means that if
there are multiple sheep for instance we
would want to identify all of them
semantic segmentation definitely quite a
bit more challenging because here we
want pixel wise labels so we want to be
able to have a pixel wise boundary
around the different elements in the
scene an instant segmentation is we
actually want to know where things are
different we don't want to just know
sheep
no sheep a B C D and E so object
detection with consonants the a popular
approach that was used sort of initially
is just to say well detection is just a
classification problem everywhere in the
image so let's just sweep a sliding
window across the whole image in all
positions preferably at all scales as
well and we'll just feed each of those
individual bounding boxes into a
classifier which will say yes or no for
all of the different classes this is
actually not quite as bad as it sounds
it's bad if you do it naively it can be
done sort of it can be done with a
little bit more optimization so that
it's not horrible but it's it's just not
great you end up with the same object
gets detected multiple times so you
would get sort of multiple 20 different
detections of the person with with
jitter around it and you also so yeah
you get that the same object gets
detected multiple times and you also are
sort of assuming that you have just a
fixed number of sizes of bounding boxes
and aspect ratios instead you could say
well I'm just going to directly predict
the bounding box so there you say
where's an object
let me just regress four numbers the
coordinates of the box so you can just
directly use a mean squared error loss
and say I want to regress the pixel
coordinates of the top left corner in
the bottom right corner for instance and
this is not as it actually works it's
sort of a strange thing to ask a neural
network to do at least I've always
thought that but it sort of works sort
of a problem though the number of boxes
is unknown and it doesn't work as well
as other approaches so
and the the last sort of general method
for doing object detection is to predict
is to take some bounding box proposals
which might come from a trained Network
and say for each of those proposals of
where there might be a bounding box
let's classify if there's actually an
object there or not let's look a little
bit more as to what that what that looks
like and then those proposals get passed
through a classifier and we can decide
if they're actually if there's actually
something there or not so and and this
provides something that looks a little
bit like a tension so instead of looking
at the whole network I'm gonna first use
one classifier to say here's some
candidate places to look now I look just
those places more closely and I decide I
refine that bounding box and I say yes
or no what sort of object is in there
and this is a lot faster because we're
not exhaustively considering the whole
image there's no reason to sweep a
window across a big field if of empty
space or a big blue sky we immediately
sort of home in on possible possible
objects and so this is I'll talk for a
couple slides about faster our CN n our
CN n stands for region CN n and this has
gone through a couple of iterations in
the last couple of years with people
coming up with refinements on the basic
on the basic approach so we start with
convolutional layers that are
pre-trained on imagenet and then there
is a proposal stage where we have a one
network here that looks at the feature
layer the feature layers of the
confident and says I'm going to produce
a number of proposals and these are
bounding box box estimates then you fill
in those bounding boxes with the actual
details and send it to a classifier and
that classifier is going to refine the
location like I said
and decide what class of object is in
there if any and also maybe do some
region of interest pooling if you have
sort of multiple detection x' in the
same area yes yes you can
so the so you I will actually go to the
next slide because it offers a little
bit more details here as to what's
actually happening here and there might
actually be and I thought there might be
a little bit more details on the actual
equations but let me let me talk about
this maybe then it's it's a little bit
more clear so what we do start with a so
we have a convolutional feature map and
we slide a window across there but it's
sort of a big course window for each
position of that window we actually look
at a selection of what we call what are
called anchor boxes and these offer a
variety of different aspect ratios the
sort of a bunch of templates that says
let's look at these different course
sort of shapes in the image and for each
of these then we're going to we're going
to predict whether or not there are
these different boxes with these
different anchor boxes with respect to
this anchor location and we're going to
predict if the proposal contains an
object so let's see here so we take this
sliding window and we take the anchor
boxes and we're actually considering the
content in there and that's what makes
this differentiable is that we still
have a sliding window approach we're
just considering a limited number of
different options and then we go through
an intermediate layer that's got you
know 256 hiddens there and
we can produce two things here one is
for each of those anchor positions then
what what are the scores with regard to
whether or not there's an object there
and then whether and then a refinement
on the coordinates and one of the most
important things here this looks similar
to the other approach but the important
thing here is that everything is in
reference to that fixed to this sliding
window location it's anchored there so
when we are predicting what the new
coordinates are and how to refine that
bounding box then it's then it is
relative to this central position and
that makes the neural network a lot more
able to scale and makes it truly
translation invariant across the entire
image space which is important otherwise
if you're asking the neural network to
produce information about whether or not
this bounding box should be moved to you
know pixel 687 versus 689 then those
aren't numbers that neural networks work
with very well with a lot of precision
and so this is used instead of this
approach well I'm not sure exactly what
this cartoon is supposed is supposed to
show but I think it shows that we're
producing proposals separately and here
we're not we're really just considering
the we're refining this this this method
of scrolling across the entire image
space it's a little bit more like a very
structured convolutional layer because
it's looking everywhere at these
different aspect ratios and to further
improve the performance we can always
because this is differentiable then we
can back prop all the way through to
this to this to the convolutional stack
and to those feature layers and make
them a little bit better a little bit
more sensitive which is important
sometimes when we get
at the end of training on imagenet we
get these sort of we don't get crisp
locations if we want to get bounding
boxes we need crisp locations in the
image so it can be useful to pre trade
and you get a little bit different
feature representation that way all
right
next let's talk for a moment about
semantic segmentation so semantic
segmentation means that we are going to
label each pixel in the input image into
one of the different object classes that
we have available and the the usual way
this is done is to classify each pixel
for each class so that you end up
getting the output of your system it's
going to be a full resolution map so the
same resolution as the input image and
but with the number of channels that's
equal to the number of classes you have
and each each of those layers is a is a
binary mask that looks for different
that looks for each different class or
has a likelihood in it it hasn't been
thresholded and so one of the important
things here when we consider doing
semantic segmentation using a
convolutional network is that what
happens at the end of a convolutional
network we have pooled and we have you
know sort of lost lost resolution so
that we end up with something that's
very semantically Laden at the end of a
say an image net continent but we don't
anymore have any spatial resolution so
going back to that the full resolution
input size is sort of the trick to to be
done here so one way to do this is to
use the different resolution preserving
building blocks that current Auk Taback
Uppal of weeks ago so to reverse the
pooling then we can do a transposed
convolution which deconvolute s-- or up
samples and we can also replace regular
convolutions with a dilated convolution
with a stride of one
let's see how that works eh
we can look at a like I said in the
usual I guess this is a vgg net in a
usual Network we would have the input
resolution and then as we go through
this through the layers of this network
then we lose spatial resolution as we
add feature layers so the output here
would be 21 different layers but we
don't know any longer have any or much
of any spatial resolution so I've got 21
different layers representing 21
different classes and I've got a
probability for each of those layers
whether or not there's an object there
but I've now I am far too coarsely
sampled far too high of a low of a
resolution so one way to do this is to
simply say well I'm going to get to that
point and then I am going to up sample
and I'm going to use a transposed
convolution and that's going to increase
the spatial resolution and I'm going to
get back to the scale the the resolution
that I want or stop stop somewhere in
the middle at some intermediate scale
this does not work that well as you
might guess why because you're going
through a bottleneck here where you're
losing a lot of the information about
where things are so really what you're
going to end up with if you train this
is what we have here you get blobs
they're nice blobs but they're not
really what we're what we're looking for
so we basically have that semantic
information as to what objects are there
but we've lost the positions so one way
to deal with this is to say I like the
information that's here that tells me
what classes are wait what classes are
in the image but I need to know where
they are so that information should
still be there in a previous layer so
what I'm going to do
is to combine this this representation
with a skip connection from here and I'm
going to bring these two together and so
this would I would have to do a 32x up
sampled prediction but if I have
combined together a previous layer with
the current confident and learned that
combination right so this can be a
learned connection here
I learned fully connected usually a
linear layer then what I can now do now
I've got a space that has the semantic
information has more resolution and I
can just do a 16x up sample to get
something more like this or obviously I
can repeat this I can say let me have
actually information from further back
in the architecture when I had even more
higher resolution information and bring
that together and be able to now have a
representation with features more
resolution now I can just do an 8x up
sampled prediction of the actual mask
and get a better result at the end yes
to be honest let's see here we are doing
a we are taking this information and we
are doing a 2x up sampling of this so
just repeating information every 2 by 2
right and then we are combining it with
we're adding another layer that is the
that's just a copy right so now we would
have two layers and these are of course
many feature layers here but I've got
one that I've simply copied the
information to up sample at once and
I've added in another layer that gives
the features then I can then this up
sampled this transposed convolution that
I'm doing here has more to work with
it's got both information at both layers
the course semantic information and also
that and then if I just keep on doing
this that two by two then I get
reasonable this notion of using of
having an architecture by the way that
has a bottleneck which is very useful
for learning an abstract semantic
disentangled however you want to call it
learns a good representation of the data
but combining that with a skip
connection it's very powerful
architecture and it's you see this theme
coming up in different types of work so
you guys looked at auto-encoders yes so
there you see that you have a similar
sort of thing even though that is a
would be trained in a different way is
an unsupervised approach but where you
want to start at some
resolution of your data you want to
learn a representation that gets sort of
narrower and narrower goes through a
bottleneck and then you want to go back
to some sort of a back to a finer
resolution so you add these skipped
connections right so I've got this
bottleneck architecture and then these
skip connections that help carry that
information through the other side so
it's just sort of a I find that there's
a lot of different sort of applications
of neural networks that end up I often
don't want the small amount of knowledge
I often want something a little bit
bigger and using skip connections to
lower layers can be very helpful and of
course this is the one of the idea the
the idea that grounds residual networks
is having that residual or skip
connection yes yeah I mean I also have
the question is to you know why not why
not go and step forward and I'm I'm not
positive as to whether or not they did
those experiments for this paper now the
there is a nice work a nice paper by
Jason use insky called do deep neural
networks really learn to transfer I
think it's a question Jason knows in ski
and it's just a really nice sort of
examination of if I train this big long
network then where do I want to actually
draw knowledge from when I use this for
a different task and and as you would
expect you do get that down here I've
got you know the the the information is
is very specific to the data to that
problem and they're the features are
very sort of low-level the features
being low-level means that it will
transfer very easily at a higher level
it tends to become more sort of problems
specific I think I said that the wrong
way the earlier layers are more general
the later the later you go in the
network then the more sort of problem
specific you get all the way to the
layer where you're actually classifying
a particular set of classes there aren't
any sort of magic answers but it does
give an interesting insight to this and
some interesting experiments on it for
the most part with this sort of an
architecture as with most deep learning
then there's a lot of empirical you know
experiments to say is it more useful to
draw you know from pool 3 or pool 4 or
both I guess you'd have to from both
alright yes so the classification is
going to be present there but not
explicitly here it is explicitly they're
a class label a class likelihood over
each possible class so here obviously
the information is there but what you
get is a little bit more attention to
the details for instance if one of your
classes is a person then at this level
you're going to get clearly yes there is
a person in the image but back here
you're going to get I see an arm
I see another arm I see a leg I see
another leg and together that
information gets put together so but of
course you could end up putting together
that I see a leg and a leg and an arm
and an arm and at the end say it's
actually I don't know a doll or a robot
or something like that at the highest
level right so you give you let the
highest level make that final decision
at the level of the class you're trying
to you're trying to predict the lowest
level can say
but if there's a he an arm here then
this is how I want to segment it and an
arm here so make a decision and then
come back down again what does I think
what we do I'm going you know if you ask
a kid to outline things in an image or
adults as you do for all of these
labelled data sets there's adults out
there that are grad students I don't
know he's sorry and you're saying that
you don't think that the the training on
this would generalize too right if
that's all you had as your what you're
training what you're learning from then
it would be really hard to solve the
problem if all you had was for instance
crowds of people wherever where
everything was was overlapping but
luckily that's the point of data sets
being big enough that they capture lots
of different things and sometimes you
will get humans that are you know
prototypical and sometimes you're going
to get more muddled scenes and more
noise things mislabel etc what we sort
of rely on when we train these things is
that given enough data we are going to
get enough of a learning signal to be
able to learn to learn what we want and
indeed these these approaches work
surprisingly well what they don't do
well on is you know you don't think that
there's an example here you look at
scenes where you have a people are
interested in doing semantic
segmentation I think that the number one
reason why people want to do semantic
segmentation in sort of an industry is
for autonomous cars because everybody
wants to take a street scene and
understand it you've got lidar you've
got other sensors but what you need to
know is is that a pedestrian and are
they about to cross in front of the car
or on you know understanding different
aspects of the scene so you want to do
scene segmentation there and understand
these different classes and you look at
the results that people have on these
sort of big street scenes with cars and
buildings and street signs and people
and bicyclists etc and they do really
well on parts of it but then parts of it
will will be really really poorly done
whereas humans can take just a couple of
pixels in that image given the context
of the whole scene and say yeah that's a
you know telephone pole that's not a
that's not a human so I'm both impressed
where this this sort of work has managed
to get in the last 10 years or so but
also there's still a lot more work to go
so another way to do this just look
ahead another way to do this is to
instead of using a regular convolution
at all you avoid the problem of having
the reduced resolution by using
throughout the network you can use a
dilated convolution and so this means
that you are removing your pooling
altogether and you are replacing
convolution with a dilated convolution
with a step size of one if you think
about how that works you're actually
going to end up with you have this broad
receptive field meaning you're looking
at a larger part of the image to make a
decision which is one of the reasons why
we do pooling is so that a convolutional
filter can look it can have a receptive
window that's broader on the scene so
that you get more high-level information
but instead we can sort of say well I'm
just going to look at every other pixel
but I'm going to move this thing slowly
across the whole image right so this
allows you to have the
same receptive field but have no
decrease in the resolution as you go
through the layers of the network and
this gives you it's sort of a simpler
architecture because you don't need to
worry about getting back up to the full
resolution and it also gives higher
accuracy because now you're really a
little bit more just directly training
for the type of information that you
want you're saying simultaneously give
me precision pixel level precision and
give me high level information and let
the network weight sort of work out how
to do this from this sort of a structure
does that make sense
all right and video classification with
confidence I went to cvpr which is the
biggest conference that looks at it does
computer vision that works in the
computer vision domain and I was still
struck by how many papers were there
that we're focusing on single images the
world is not presented to us as single
images why aren't we working on video
but there's still a lot of work being
done but we do have means of doing
classification and segmentation and all
of these sorts of problems in videos so
here's a few different ways to ways to
do this first of all starting on the
Left we can just say well I'm going to
process one frame at a time right I'm
going to pretend that my video is just a
set of images that may or may not be
related and I'm just going to run a
continent through every single one of
them this is sort of like doing a
sliding window approach to do detection
using a classifier network this is sort
of exhaustively looking for dogs for
instance by considering separately every
single frame this is inefficient
but moreover it doesn't work well
because the whole point of considering
multiple frames is that you can build up
your certainty over time when I see just
a couple pixels of a light post and I'm
trying to figure out if it's a light
post or a person down the road then I
want to see you know more information
just getting a few more few more samples
can help me make that decision so
another way to do this is I'm going to
run my classifier over all of the images
but then I'm going to train a layer
that's going to so imagine we're
training the same or we're running the
same convolutional net work
independently over each frame in this
video sequence but then at the end I'm
taking a I'm taking the outputs of
across all of those frames and I'm
training one network one layer at the
top to say there's a there's been a dog
scene there's been a human scene
something like that so late fusion early
fusion let's instead take advantage of
the fact of the let's use the neural
network to reason about multiple images
at the same time so instead we feed in a
block of images so instead of my input
being RGB now I've got n different
images stacked up and my convolutions
then can go in my confident can go
across the image space and sort of XY
but they can also go through the time
direction as well so just a simple
extension on your standard convolutional
Network and everything is exactly the
same it's just now my input is a block
of images rather than a single one and
we can call this an early fusion model
this means that my network all along the
way obviously I would need to fine-tune
this but along the way I would be able
to make a better decision because I'm
looking at those features and motion at
a lower level
another approach would be slow fusion
and the idea here is that I'm going to
do some of both I'm going to run
independent feature extractors
confidence over each individual frame
but then I'm going to in the middle
start to put these together I will point
out this is for vid video classification
but we consider exactly the same gamut
of different options all right yes I'll
take the question first does which
approach work so they do work the the
thing that sort of that's not great here
is that all of these approaches assume a
fixed temporal window that I'm going to
consider right they all assume that you
know for instance that ten frames is
good enough to detect everything so that
means that you're not going to be able
to see a glimpse of the tail of a dog
and then the head of a dog you know 20
frames later and be able to say I saw a
dog so and you can always construct a
case where you want to have a wider
temporal window or where a narrower one
would be better this is exactly the
motivation for using a recurrent neural
network instead which is probably what
Oriole talked about last week maybe or
did you talk about text yeah okay yes
right so you can definitely use a
dilated convolution in overtime and be
able to get a much better a much better
field of view temporally in exactly the
same way that we want to might want a
broader field of view over the the image
space and this is that's what's used for
for instance pixel net or wave net pixel
net wave net these approaches they take
they process a nut pixel net because
that would be pixels wave net is an
approach that does that does speech
generation or audio generation and it
learns via dilated temporal convolutions
exactly I the the slight tangent that I
wanted to mention is that we're talking
here about video about a single modality
but this is the this is the same gamut
of different approaches that we consider
any time when you have two modalities so
if I've got say audio and video which is
honestly what we should be looking at
not even just a video we sort of
understand the world through the media
of audio and video now you've got these
two different modalities how do I
understand those do i process them
completely separately and then at the
end put them together and try to solve
my problem you know do do speech
recognition or some problem from there
or do i somehow fuse together these
different sensory modalities early on we
do the same thing in robotics if I've
got a robotic arm then I want to be able
to both process my image of that hand
moving as well as the proprioception
which means what is the joint position
you know my knowledge of how what my
hand what my joints are doing their
velocity but
so tactile information right I've got
these different sorts of information
coming in how can I combine those what
is the best way and I think that this is
an extremely interesting question
because you can really you you can come
up with arguments for any of these
different approaches and with and
without recurrent networks and etc there
isn't a best answer but I think that
there should be a little bit more
principled you know research and
understanding of why to use these when
how to use the different architectures
interestingly all right quick tangent to
in the brain they used to think and I'm
saying this from a colleague of mine I
am NOT a neuroscientist but I was told
that they that neuroscientists used to
think that there was late fusion of
different sensory modalities in the
brain so the way in which we process
audio the way we process vision whatever
else then those get fused sort of at the
end so there's the independent things
they've and that was because you have
your visual cortex you have your
auditory cortex etc and the two are
relatively separate just recently
they've discovered actually there's all
of these pathways that go in between so
that maybe looks a little bit more like
this or like this but with lateral
connections here so there's some
separation there different dedicated
processing but then there are all of
these pathways of connections that allow
the two to communicate so that you can
get feedback early on in the cortical
processing between what I'm hearing and
seeing and touching etc which makes
sense quick example of doing of a
specific means of doing a processing
video the idea here is that we want to
use two sources of information
one being the motion and one being the
visual information the idea is is that
maybe if we prot if we understand sort
of process these separately
that we can get a better results better
accuracy of doing action recognition I'm
pretty sure that this was for action
recognition
fact I'm sure it wasn't so we trained or
this is actually from Karen in andrew
zisserman you trained to confidence and
one of them is going to have as its
input a stack of images and the other
one is going to have as its input a
single image and what you're going to
try to do here is you're going to hit
you're going to train this with a loss
that tries to predict the optical flow
and you're going to train this one with
that is predicting I don't remember my
guess is that you're predicting here the
that it's pre trained using image net
and then we've got a neural network
layer fully connected layer that brings
that has its input the two output layers
of these two different sort of pathways
and unifies them and comes up with the
signal single classification of what
type of action is this okay that's the
end of that section maybe let's do the
five minute break now and then I can
jump into the next section so this is a
paper from a couple years ago from Max
yata Berg deep mind and just to motivate
it let's think about convolutional
neural networks they have pooling layers
why do they have pooling layers because
we want more invariance translational
invariance right we want to be able to
have the same activations we want to
pool together activations over broader
areas or rather sorry convolutional
layers give us
you know translational invariance some
amount of it and pooling sort of
accommodates different spatial
translations to give a more uniform
result and make the learning easier so
pooling does two things pooling
increases the the field of view for the
next layer and says now I'm looking at
information over a bigger projection
onto the original image so that I can
make a more a higher-level feature
detection but it also acts to say
whether I saw the arm here or here or
here or here it's still an arm so it
works in concert with the convolutional
operator which is able to do to give a
uniform detection across different areas
and it pools that together so that it
just has representation of yes there was
an arm I don't care where it was but the
this this nice system only works
strictly you know only works for for
translations and there's lots of other
types of transformations that we're
going to see in particular and a visual
scene and it's hard coded into the
architecture as well so various people
have come up with cool architectures
where now the weight tying is instead of
just having a convolution this way then
you also have weight tying across
different rotations and there's
different ways to do this it gets a
little bit ugly though right but the
usual thing is to just say well if I
want to detect M nist digits you know
that are turned upside down or faces
that are turned upside down I'm just
going to learn on a lot of data so that
the basically then you need to learn to
recognize fours versus 7s when the
right-side up and when they're sideways
and when they're upside down so you're
making more work because you
have anything that's in your in your
architecture it's that's innate that
will accommodate these sort of
transformations so let's learn to
transform the input instead yes exactly
exactly so this is done routinely a
called data augmentation where I'm going
to introduce some variations to my data
so that I can learn across that
obviously it makes the learning harder
ok now I've got a confident that yes it
recognizes rotations and and and this is
and this is still the the standard
approach and a wise thing to do this
offers a different complimentary
approach that's sort of interesting
because it's a way of tailoring what
sort of in variances you want to your
actual problem so here's the here's the
the challenge I'm given data that looks
like this different orientations
wouldn't it be nice if I had a magical
transform that recognized what sort of
or what sort of transformations there
are in my input space and got me to a
canonical pose such that my Convenant
has a little bit less work to do
that's true and that you're right that
you know the these low level the first
layer of Gabor filters what look like
Gabor filters are extremely general and
have all of the rotations in them and so
but the problem is is that in order to
recognize this versus this I need
different filters to do that so I would
need the entire gamut of different
filters which we have but that's to
recognize that that's to recognize
different different types of things I
mean the problem is not at the first
level it's somewhere in the middle when
I start wanting to put these together to
recognize a7 and I'd much rather be able
to assume that a 7 always has a point
going you know in the same orientation
if I have to recognize that particular
little V feature its distinctive of a7
in all orientations I have to have that
at the next layer as well so just having
all rotations of my Gabor filters the
first level doesn't give me the
rotational invariance at the next level
or at the highest level alright so if we
were to make this differentiable then
ideally we'd be able to learn a
transformation there that would be
useful for exactly my data type rather
than saying externally I want to build
in rotation invariance what if I don't
know exactly what sort of problems there
are and my data or what the canonical
pose that would be most useful for faces
we have an idea for other types of data
who knows I just know that I've got a
lot of data it's got a lot of different
variants and is there some way of making
this a little bit more homogeneous so
that when I apply my confident it
doesn't have to work quite so hard so
that's the idea of learning tea learning
something that will transform this to
make it understood we can think about
this more generally this goes back to
your question
those first level Gabor filters are
pretty useful in pretty general already
may
I want to just keep those here maybe I
just want to have something that I can
insert between two layers to say take
this input take this output from one
layer of my processing and transform it
before you feed it into the next layer
and learn how to do this then you might
get that this transformation here is not
very useful so you would hope to just
learn an identity there this might be
the useful one where I would want to get
some sort of rotation for instance to a
canonical pose so this is the
convolutional network in a nutshell the
idea is that again I'm imagining that
this is planted between two other layers
of processing so I have some input you
previous feature layers what I want to
do is to first predict theta so these
are the parameters for some set of
transformations that parameterize is
this function tau which is my grid
generator that's going to produce a
sampling grid the output of this is an
actual sampler which is going to take
the features in you and turn it into my
input into the my next layer processing
V
illumination is fairly I mean sure yes
you could
illumination you're right you could get
a better normalization than you would
get through the bias correction that you
get sort of for free and a convolutional
Network the bias correction that you get
and a convent net is going to apply to
the whole to the whole feature layer so
you're right you might get a nice sort
of normalization of of it if you could
do if you could do something a little
bit different
often illumination does get handled
fairly well by a confident already as
long as it as you don't train it on dark
images and then try to test them outside
of the set so this relies in order to
make this differentiable then we want to
have a components which are
differentiable so here we consider these
three components like I said first we
have something which is called the
localization net which is going to be a
trainable function that's really doing
all of the work here this is the thing
that it's where we're actually
optimizing parameters that's going to
map our features to our trans
transformation function the grid
generator is going to take those
parameters that have been inferred from
my current input theta and create a
sampling grid and then the actual
sampler is going to do the do the
transformation and feed it in today and
feed into the next layer so this is
simply I am going to use r6 because
we'll start out by just thinking about
affine transformations there are
different types of that that's the one
thing that you do need to define is you
do need to say what is my transformation
function that I am going to be embedding
here the rest of it the actual
parameters of it what that
transformation
is is going to be determined by this
localization that per each image that
comes in which is why we're not just
applying a general rotation to all the
images but each one is going to be
rotated or transformed separately but
one could use the same approach and have
many different types of functions
embedded there so we have a trainable so
first of all the localization Network is
a trainable function that's going to act
on the outputs of you and produce theta
and so our forward pass just looks like
normal inference with a neural network
of your choice with the neural layer of
your choice some sets of weights right
second component the grid generator
so this is parametrized by the theta
which we have inferred and this
generates an output map and so we're
going to have a output we're going to
take our parameters theta and we're
going to produce something that is in
the same size the same dimensions of our
of V of where we are going into and then
the last piece of sorry still in the the
grid generator so this is the forward
pass that we would use for affine
transforms to be specific about it the
the six estimates of theta that give
that rotation translation scale and so
we can think about this as being that
the output of the grid generator is a
sampling grid that says for each
component in that for X s and YS then
I'm going to index into my input
map to figure out where I should sample
that to get my new my new output and the
sampler is going to the sampler is going
to actually do the sampling to fig to
apply a kernel function to say where in
how am I going to get go from u to V
based on the mapping given to me with XS
YS and the forward passed there then
looks like this general formula which
uses some kernel function and then we
can look at this for a particular
transformation in her particular
sampling sampler such as bilinear
interpolation and that gets me to a
specific formula for what that sampler
is going to look like for the forward
pass and as long as this is
differentiable with respect to x and y
then you're good and I think it is for
all kernels right so now we need to go
in the opposite direction so we've
looked at our forward pass localization
network the grid generator the sampler
and that creates the new input and then
we proceed onwards as we're coming
backwards through the network we want to
first back propagate through that
bilinear sampler to get the derivatives
of V with respect to with respect to U
and x and y right so here we've got the
gradients going this way the gradients
going that way
and so this is the derivative of V with
respect to you going through that
bilinear interpolation and this is with
respect to X I and why I would be the
same and this uses this has
discontinuities in it so we use sub
gradients because of the Max next
through up to backprop through the grid
generator the function tau and we need
to because we want to get to the
derivative of x and y with respect to
theta with respect to our output from
the localization Network and last we are
going to back prop the localization
Network in the usual way because that's
neural layers it's just going to be a
set of weights and a bias may be a
non-linearity and that will give us the
the gradient of theta with respect to U
and that sorry and then we can and then
we can obviously continue to back prop
through whatever other things we have in
our network stack at that point but
really this is just a matter of sort of
choosing things to begin with that were
reasonably differentiable even if
there's discontinuities and being able
to have that produce those those
gradients so let's take a look at how
this works maybe this video is working
don't have any control over the video
all right so this video actually started
earlier so what do we see happening here
these are two different so those are an
affine function that's been used there
okay I can step through it okay so
there's a bunch of experiments that
we're done on this I almost all of them
with em nest although not all and the
idea here is to try different types of
transformations such as a thin plate
spline versus an affine transformation
as the sort of chosen space of functions
and then we can see how it does and what
we're seeing in first on the left is
what the input is and then and all we're
trying to do here note that the only way
that we're training this is by trying to
predict what the what the digit is right
we're just trying to predict if it's a
five so this means that it's up to the
network to [ __ ] to produce this spatial
transformer like I said this could just
end up being identity and that is
exactly what you get if your inputs are
relatively well normalized centered etc
but if you start moving them around then
what you learn is this transformation
that gives you in the the output after
that spatial transformer is quite stable
it's not completely stable but it's
stable enough for the rest of the
continent to do a better job on this and
that that's sort of the the important
take-home here this was also used for M
NIST edition so I've now got to the I've
got two channels being fed in together
that and we have two and we have two
different spatial Transformers one
learns to trans to stabilize channel one
the other one learns to transform
channel two and in this case the only
thing that we're training it on is what
the out what you know three plus eight
is is what the output is of image a plus
image B which makes it into a harder
problem and just demonstrates that you
can still learn through this complex
architecture and get something
reasonable
lots of moving things yeah right more
moving things with noise I can't move
past this there we go
okay next I'd like to talk about yes you
can I don't remember it's a good it's a
good question
obviously six and nine is a little bit
of a problem I'm not sure if they
constrained it to not be a full rotation
beat for that reason that'd be a problem
for you as well I would point out
there's no magic here yeah go ahead
because otherwise if you don't use a
kernel to sample the input then what
you're going to get in the output is
something that is very has holes in it
and is less accurate that's why we if
you're if you're sampling an image into
a warp some transform then you need to
use a kernel at least bilinear
interpolation is going to give you
something smoother than using
nearest-neighbor
which is going to give you something
smoother than just using the targeted
pixel no it's just about retaining more
of the information content
I mean imagine that my transformation is
is zooming in then I'm going to be
sampling a lot all in one area and
you're going to end up with it being you
know the areas between different pixels
get sort of blown up and distorted and
it's not going to look smooth it's the
same thing you get if you try with
different sampling techniques and you're
you know just an image processing
program on the computer you get quite
differ
results if you use different types of
kernel sampling know the only learned
part there is in the theta is in the
localization net the rest of it is just
turn the crank it's just machinery put
in place that we can back prop through
the sampling is what's actually
transforming the output of you into
something normalized that we feed into V
no not sampling in that sense all right
we good to go yes it's a nice paper if
you want a nice read on this this method
I enjoy the spatial transformer paper
alright
learning relationship so rather than
learning classification or regression
sometimes that's not the goal sometimes
we just want to know similarity and
dissimilarity for instance so I don't
want to know yeah enough said
sometimes we want to do visualization in
which case it's not really interesting
to set two to do classification we want
to know how a bunch of data is all
related and so for the purpose of
visualization I might want to infer
relationships between between things you
know if I understand x and y how do I
really said to two x and y I might want
to do clustering or I might want to
understand something fundamental about
the underlying structure of a set of
data so these are all cases in which it
is not may not be helpful or possible to
do a standard supervised learning
approach like classification or
regression fundamentally they all relate
to taking something that's high
dimensional and producing something that
is low dimensional but that still
capture
some properties of the data that we care
about and that's we call that people are
very quite loose in their terminology
there but this is generally called the
the embedding of the data or the
manifold of the data learning so in a
standard so one way to do this that
people often use if they've trained a
imagenet network for instance for
classification or you can just simply
take off the classification layer and
then you can say aha there's my
embedding right there's my feature space
maybe a hundred dimensional or you know
something higher but I'm just going to
say that is my manifold of the data and
that works for some cases and you might
do this but you may not have any
training lay labels or you might want to
generalize to new classes in which case
having this this trained doesn't really
make sense so a different way to do this
is to think about this in terms of not
supervised learning where we associate
each input with a label but instead have
embedding losses which in which
associate inputs with each other right
so fundamental idea here pull similar
things together push dissimilar things
apart in that manifold space right these
are just similar but they look similar
we want these to be separate we don't
want these to get mapped together if you
looked at excel wise similarities those
are going to get those are going to be
maybe not nearest neighbors but pretty
close right in in our pixel space we
want to learn a space where these are
far apart these are both buses we want
them to be mapped together so that's an
example of where we're actually taking
the label of the object so we could just
do super
on these or we could use this these
labels in other ways and there might be
other reasons why we have information
about which things are similar in which
things are different get back to that
moment all right so how do we design
losses for this if now I just have a
relationship between two inputs rather
than and rather than a label that I'm
trying to predict so typically all of
these approaches involve distances in
feature space often an l2 distance so
one example is a contrastive squared
loss so here we say that I'm going to
take two inputs X I and XJ and I'm going
to take a label but this is a similarity
label so it says either these are
similar or these are different for X I
and XJ and I am going to have a my loss
function is going to say that I am going
to pay if Y IJ equals 1 which means that
these are similar then I want them to be
close in my feature space and I'm going
to pay a cost if they are far apart
quadratic cost for them being far apart
if they are if Y I equals negative 1
which means that they are dissimilar
then I'm going to pay a cost for having
them close together and I want to push
them further apart up to a margin if you
don't have this margin M on your space
then you will be trying to push things
explode it's infinitely far apart it's
not well constrained so this is a
contrastive squared loss where I've got
two different penalties depending on
which samples I haven't if I want to
pull them closer in my in my space which
is a function f or if I want to push
them further apart and I trained my
network with this and it's sort of like
a like an energy system where I'm going
to be just trying to rearrange my
feature space such that the
these different things are these two
different constraints workout pardon me
the x-axis would be the distance in the
the distance in the feature space the
Lydian distance between f of X I and F
of XJ and the y-axis is the is the cost
as the loss and so this can be trained
using something that has been called a
Siamese Network where I have an
identical copy of F I passed X I through
the through F I pass XJ through F I
compute this distance including and
distance between them in the in their
feature space and then I'm going to back
prop through the through the network and
they since they share weights then then
both sides get are updated we can use
different losses this can use this uses
a cosine similarity loss so here we have
that our distance D is the cosine
similarity between f of X I and F of XJ
and I have forgotten there's some
there's there some work that that sort
of compares and contrasts between these
these two these two different losses for
similarities honestly forgotten what the
R is the the result of it was that
method C which is the next one worked
better I don't remember what the
comparison was between the first two
that I showed so the third way the third
formulation that's often used and that
I'd say is most common common now is
called a triplet loss and the triplet
loss see if I have another the idea here
is that I'm going to have
three points that are input so I've got
X a X s and X D and what I know is
simply the relative information that XD
is X s is more similar to the anchor
than X D is so what you want to do is
push and pull the system train your
weights such that you go from that or it
from that to that so you're never trying
to completely pull two elements together
and you're never trying to push two
elements completely apart you're just
saying relative if I take three things I
want to move pull one closer and push
one further away and this works very
well it's nice in general it's it's
balanced the training works well doesn't
explode and the loss function is just as
you would think that you're going to try
to the distance between the between the
dissimilar one you're going to pay a
penalty if that is much larger than the
distance from the similar one and
there's a margin there as well and how
are these used so one one interesting
way in which they're used is that all of
the face detection algorithms that are
out there these days all use this
approach and why is that
well that's because people used to do
face recognition by saying okay I'm
going to take a hundred people and take
a bunch of photos of each one and I want
to be able to recognize I'm going to
classify each of those people so I'm
going to I'm going to recognize by name
by ID each of those people and that's
how I'm going to tell if two people are
different as if they come up with
different IDs when I run a classifier on
their on their faces or if they're
saying they come up with the same ID
this is a problem when you have lots and
lots of people
Facebook has too many people
to be able to use anything like this it
doesn't scale to do use classifier
instead all you want to know is given
two images are they the same person or
are they different people so instead you
use this method of training and
embedding space and then all you have to
look at is the distance in that really
nice feature space that you've made and
that will tell you what the likelihood
is that two images are of the same
person and I don't any longer need to
actually keep the I mean obviously the
IDs are there but you don't need to
explicitly learn using those IDs so for
instance this is from face neck-deep
face I think is the best one currently
but that might be a little bit old but
this is from face net which is also very
good these are all images of the same
person and they're all taken as nearest
neighbors from one image in the feature
space so you can tell by that that if
those are all nearest neighbors of one
point then you've learned something
that's really really robust to all the
different ways in which people can can
look can appear yes similar distantly
yeah you get that to some extent with
the triplet loss but yes you could you
could definitely take the original the
the contrastive squared loss and you can
instead of just using a binary class of
class on that then you could use a
continuous continuous class and that
will simply change how it works so there
has been a couple papers that have done
that and on the other side of it so
that's how well it works these are false
accepts so each of these pears pear pear
pear pear pear pear pear those are all
incorrectly matched by deep face as well
your face net so incorrectly it thought
these two were the same person and
clearly they're completely different
people so yes we would we would make
most of the same so these facial
recognition networks are now better
significantly better than humans can do
on the same problem although that's
that's from a data set I think that
humans do better if you actually know
the person right so the people that we
know that we work with and our families
our friends etc we still luckily beat
the the confidence at robustly
recognizing the identity of those images
but if it's just a data set then then we
lose all right I have maybe 15 minutes
left I was going to run through
something that I worked on is that sound
alright okay so it probably uses a bunch
of a bunch of things in deep RL that you
guys have not have not covered yet but
yes yeah there's a lot of different way
that that's one of the cool things about
it is that there's a lot of different
ways of getting those those relationship
labels right so you can take images take
lots and lots of images and just say
well if if two objects appear together
next to each other then yes we should
definitely say that these two things
have some similarity to them if I never
see two things together there should be
different and distant in the feature
space and then you get something that
will group together office stuff versus
outdoor stuff etc you can also use this
so somebody used this to say I don't
understand this biological data that I'm
getting in some test that was being done
on cancer patients I don't understand
this I don't know what the structure is
but I do know that I get the these these
readings from individual patients
so they just said let's group these
together right and then just say that if
the same if these readings come from the
same patient then they should have some
similarity I think it was from two
different tests that were being done
that were not obviously correlated but
they understood a sort of an unknown
structure in different types of cancer
because of this and that was just a
matter of saying there's a relationship
between these because they're coming
from the same person you can also use
this for temporal information so you can
just say that in streaming video frames
that are close to each other should be
more similar than frames that are
further apart from each other and then
you get something that's often referred
to as slow features you get this very
different sort of features where you get
where things are very invariant over
short amounts of time or transformations
so yes very very broad area can do a lot
of different things with with these
approaches all right so I like
navigation navigations a fun problem we
all navigate I navigate you navigate I
wanted to make a problem in a simulator
that I could try different deep
reinforcement learning approaches on and
I started working on this at a time when
deep mind had was just working on Atari
and I really wanted to go beyond Atari
in terms of a set of interesting
problems and so navigation mazes have
the problem of that if you can look at
the maze from here you can solve the
maze if you're looking at it from there
it becomes much more challenging because
you only have partial observability of
of the domain so I need to remember
things over time and I need to learn to
recognize structure just from a visual
input so I worked with my colleagues at
the mine we developed a simulator to
produce these procedurally produce these
mazes and we made up a game that says
I'm going to start somewhere in this
maze anywhere in this maze and I'm going
to try to find the goal if I find the
goal I get plus 10 points and I
immediately get teleported somewhere
else and I
have to find my way back again and I'm
going to repeat that as quickly as I can
for a fixed episode length right wander
around the maze find the goal get
teleported elsewhere find your way back
again get teleported find your way back
that's the goal there's also some apples
laying around these help with getting
the learning off the ground we found out
later they're not necessary but they're
there for for because we assumed
initially that we would need those in
order to start the learning process we
can look at different variants here so
we could say well we've got a static
maze in the static goal and the thing
that changes is where the agent gets
gets spawned where you start and where
you get teleported to or we can say well
the maze layout is fixed but I've got a
goal that moves around on every episode
or I can say everything is random all
the time and the inputs I get are the
RGB image and then my velocity just my
instantaneous velocity in ancient
relative coordinate frame and I can take
actions that involve moving sideways
forward backwards we're rotating looking
around and I can look at a few different
mazes we have a large one takes about
five minutes per episode almost 11,000
steps in an episode so longer space of
time and bigger mazes and we also have
that little what we call the eye maze
where the goal is only appears in the
four corners and the agent always starts
somewhere in the middle here and you
really just you know exactly the
behavior you want you want the agent to
methodically check the four corners when
it finds the goal just immediately go
back there again but you can see from
these sorts of traces this is after
learning that it has finds the goal and
then goes back there again and again
throughout the episode so that's the
problem in an in a very quick nutshell
so the
what we have a sparse rewards it makes
this this we can train an agent using
sort of standard deep reinforcement
learning methods on the game I present
it but it's slow it is hard to do it's
slow takes a long time very data if in
efficient we discovered that we could
substantially accelerate the speed of
the learning if we used auxilary losses
so this means that instead of just
trying to maximize reward through
learning a value function and updating
the policy I'm also at the same time
going to predict simple things in my
environment just using supervised
learning or unsupervised learning
depending on how you want to call it and
we decided to try using depth prediction
and loop closure prediction so what is
so and I will tell you what that moment
means more in a moment first of all
let's take a look at the architecture
that we used so our input is RGB images
feed it through a convolutional encoder
three layers then we add a two layer LS
TM so we need to have memory for this
task right I need to be able to get to
the goal and then remember where it was
so I can efficiently get back to it so
we know that we need memory we use an LS
TM we used to just two is better and we
have a skip connection from the
Convenant said skip connections are
useful general tools and that helps the
learning we can add some additional
inputs to the system the instantaneous
velocity like I said just an agent
relative coordinates how fast I'm moving
laterally and rotationally previous
action previous reward and then we
trained this using a three C which is a
synchronous advantage actor critic which
you will know about by the end of this
course if you don't know now but it is a
method for Policy gradient learning
where we use the case step advantage
function to update the value and
we use the thing that we are really
interested in here is the axillary tasks
so we're going to predict depth by that
I mean the input to the system is
actually RGB and D the depth in the
image space right how far away things
are we're going to not give that as an
input but instead try to predict it and
we can try to predict it as a MLP on the
convolutional features or we can do it
off of the LS TM we're trying to predict
that depth Channel and just a just a sub
sampled version of it a course
prediction of the depth of that image we
also tried experimenting with loop
closure prediction so this is just a
Bernoulli loss we're going to predict at
each time step have we been here before
at this place in the maze in this
episode and so that's off of the LS TM
because we need memory for that one and
then we actually add a position encoder
which we don't we just use this as a as
a decoder but we don't back prop
gradients through it's just to say can I
can I predict the position of the agent
from what it's thinking little heartbeat
stethoscope this produce produces a
plumbing I'm going to skip this it's in
the it's in the paper if you're
interested and we're just going to
combine all of those different losses
together by the way the axillary losses
and the RL loss we're just going to
we're just going to add them all
together and back propagate yes there
aren't that many that you can you know
this was one of the main questions was
whether or not obviously this is
something about the visual system and we
knew from some related work that this
could accelerate learning we didn't know
if
if it would work to have the gradients
have to pass through to to LST MS to get
to the visual feature layers but that
actually works very well there aren't
that many different places you can you
can attach these things and it's
relatively easy to to test the effect of
it alright so different architectures on
the left the plain vanilla a3c
feedforward no memory be we add on an
LST M make it recurrent see we call our
nav a 3c we've added our additional our
additional inputs are additional
plumbing and additional LST m and then
the last one where we add on our
auxilary losses axillary tasks okay so
how does this look on a large maze hmm
won't show the video yet okay so these
are learning curves this is over a
hundred million steps of experience in
this maze and this is what we get with
the vanilla agent without memory it
can't solve the task very well it can
just learn to be a speedy Explorer but
it can't learn to remember really
remember where it is and get back to the
goal and we ran five five seeds for each
one and we show the show the mean if we
add the LST I'm the second agent that I
showed there then we do much better but
you can say that takes a long time to
learn before we get to that inflection
point where the where we actually figure
out what's where the agent figures out
what's going on and that's what we
typically see with LST ms by the way if
we add the additional inputs and the
additional LST m then it's about the
same it's a little bit more unstable if
we add loop closure prediction then we
get fairly unstable performance
from using that because often there's
not a strong gradient signal because
often you don't close the loop again in
these mazes but it does give enough
information that you can see that the
that inflection point all of a sudden
moves to the left by well a day in terms
of training this which is nice to see if
we add on the depth prediction wow we're
way over there all of a sudden now all
of a sudden we're getting to almost peak
top performance very very very very
quickly and this is this is remarkable
to see what the difference it makes in
in this in this task and we see that it
helps in all the tasks that we tried not
always this dramatically but it always
improves if we use d2 d2 is placing the
depth prediction on the LST M instead a
little bit later to start off but
doesn't really matter and it finishes
just a smidge higher performance we can
put together d1 d2 and L so that with
the loop closure doesn't really change
things too much and for reference that's
where a human expert gets to it's that's
does much better than I do
I only get 110 points
at deepmind we have not one but two
dedicated video game players that put in
a hard 40-hour week of playing various
games we throw at them I have to say
there's something that they don't like
very much the mazes were not too bad
there were some that were pretty pretty
pretty unpleasant for them because they
tend to be quite easy Atari Atari oh
those are fun some of the other things
that we've done are fun but some things
when we're asking them to repeat playing
it twenty to a hundred times but it's a
really trivial game then they get
annoyed at us yes so they are
professionals and and and I must say
there's there's a lot of skill involved
I mean I can't come close to their
performance on various things it's
interesting we actually also tend to if
we develop a task deep mind we will say
I want to look for how we use memory or
you know different types of things or
attention or something like that we
develop it a task and we have our human
experts learn to play it and then we
interview them that we say we ask them
what was your process of learning how to
do this what did you feel what were the
key things what were you looking at you
know what were you observing what was
hard and that's can be really really
interesting really informative
I'm not sure that they've ever had a
task where they've wanted to have that
but we would probably let them do that
we just try to not give them we actually
for this because depth was an important
element then we did give them a stare
stereo goggles to to look at a
representation so that they had a
heightened sense of depth to see what
difference that that made which didn't
make any fun all right so just have one
minute left let me skip past that video
I'll show a video at the end so an
important question is here is is if
depth gives such an amazing difference
then should it why not just give it as
an input
you know why give it as a prediction
target instead and the answer is that
that actually works much better so we
compared between if we had an
architecture like this on the Left where
we fed in RGB D we just said okay here's
the depth full resolution the whole
thing then we actually don't learn as
well as if we have to predict it and
that's because the important thing here
is not the actual depth information it's
the gradients the gradients sort of
scaffold the very noisy learning that
goes on rent with reinforcement learning
if these very noisy great it's coming
from reinforcement learning if I can on
every frame give give something
meaningful that lets the network learn
something about the structure of the
scene and turn from a set of pixels into
something that's a little bit more
coherent then then it works better we
showed that the agent is memory is
remembering the goal location because it
gets to the goal faster at least on the
smaller mazes and then position decoding
it knows where it is and then you can
just see it's sort of zooming around
here so this is on the AI maze where
it's going to check the corners and it
just found the goal on the this arm of
the maze and now it's just going to
repeatedly for the rest of them
90 seconds or so of the episode is just
going to repeatedly come back here again
because it remembered where it was an
easy task but we wanted to see this this
is in a larger maze we show that we can
decode the position of the agent using
that non back propped position decoder
you can see it just zooming through very
effectively when it got to the goal it
got respawn somewhere else has to come
back again the last thing that I did
want to show here so this is because in
the mazes that are static
so the maze layout is static and only
the goal position changes then it knows
just where it is it doesn't need to go
forward so it can go backwards because
it's really memorized that maze as soon
as you train it animes that can change
where the topology of it changes over
time or changes with each episode then
you see that it pays a little bit more
attention it doesn't do the same nice
sliding moves that's true if you put in
a cost of hitting the wall then it does
it does it does worse yes exactly and to
help with the memory system and we have
actually shown that it's not the agent
does not use that the human does one of
the things we asked the human expert are
the paintings on the wall useful for
recognizing where you are and they said
yes absolutely
the agent we can take the paintings away
and you lose like an epsilon of
performance so it integrates over time
so if it's in an ambiguous space then it
can just go down the hall and it just
uses the LS TM to accumulate evidence
about where it is well done this is what
I wanted to show this is the actual
thing that's being predicted by the
agent that's the auxiliary loss that
makes all the difference there you can
see that it gives that it's it's
predicting hoarsely some
thing about the geometry of the scene
but it's interesting what if you make it
really empty I think it would probably
do fine and I have not tried that
specifically but we have tried with more
and less complex sort of wall textures
and that has not made a difference all
right I am I am all done thank you very
much